it's christmas of course and a lot of
people are wrapping presents
getting them wrapped rapping is a big
part of the christmas season so
i thought i'd learn more about this
important
holiday art form here's what i did i
paid a very quick visit to the good
people at bloomingdale's department
store where they showed me what it takes
to be a professional
gift wrapper and we brought a camera
crew and well here's what happened
i'm in the bloomingdale's here in
century city and i'm here with munji
mohammed what is your title here at
bloomingdale sir
i'm the ceo so the customer experience
leader
so your job is to make sure that the the
customers here at bloomingdale's have an
amazing experience isn't that right
absolutely and i call it pepelicious you
call it fabulicious i call it
fabulicious experience
so fabulous and delicious hearing from
corporate right now and they want you to
stop
stop calling it fabulicious i want to
help wrap
gifts who's going to teach me it would
be definitely robin
you are robin benedetti correct very
nice to meet you nice to meet you
i suppose i'm taller and better looking
than you thought i'd be you are
you think i have the skills i'm sure you
do hit that
harder harder oh harder
come on okay that was hard
uh do you want to no no i i think i can
rub up here yeah just get in there
get in there with an eye yeah yeah just
get in with your thumbs
ah that's good keep going um
so you're making me sweat just please
okay okay someone told you to stop
robin do you think you can teach me to
gift wrap at a professional level i
promise i can you know what this uh
massage is manji yeah
it's fabulicious thank you robin you
have many
beautiful wrapping papers here i'd like
to show you some of the
wrapping papers i might like to use okay
this is me as sort of a naughty santa
you like that i like that is this a
paper you would use it definitely
has possibilities it's sort of me just
saying hi there yeah
merry christmas kind of like this is two
reindeers making out
that's individual i like the conan one
better you like the conan one better
what if the conan was making out with a
deer would that be okay
this is one i like it's male
bodybuilders okay
not too holiday-ish do you think well
yeah it is
actually they're there with a package
okay
what do i need to know to wrap gifts
we're gonna wrap this box i'm gonna wrap
this box this is an empty box cause you
don't trust me with a real present
we can work our way up to real paper
next
we're going to tape it you've just uh
wrapped an empty gift
these are traditionally what i give to
my staff no it's really
funny to see them get it they're like
this is going to be good and they open
it and there's nothing inside
and i tell them you're lucky to have a
job that's my favorite part about
christmas
i like that you think it's nice very
nice do you think i'm ready to go on my
own i think you are
bam
how am i doing on time uh you're getting
there
there you go okay
when wrapping gifts it's important to
take a break every now and then
a lot of pressure i just feel like i can
talk to you for the first time
it's a very nice mattress i think i like
the bigger size though what size is this
queen have you ever wrapped a human
being before
i haven't done that i'm gonna try this
is my first time okay
i swear to god man i'm not touching her
please the present should never speak
[Music]
the woman here's the awkward part i'm
going to now uh tie you to the roof of
my car
well i learned absolutely nothing and i
wasted a lot of people's time
robin mongi thank you very much and
let's never stand this close again
you